this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much for the intro and
for the welcome I'm happy to be here and
partly because I've been kind of a SAP
about being back on campus after quite a
few years and yeah it's beautiful to be
here so originally I came to study
mechanical and aerospace engineering and
as hoping to study under Carl Sagan but
that didn't work out exactly and then
but I did get to work with Steve Squyres
and Space Sciences on some early Mars
Mars rover development work there and so
then so coming from that you know
aerospace robotics angle ended up
working on all these tools it had to do
with soils and rocks like the grinding
tool on the Mars rovers spirit and
opportunity I got to help design and
build that and operate it when it was on
Mars and actually one of them still
working on Mars now and that was all
because of the Cornell connections here
and and then after a while I thought so
I was at a private company where we
built that for the Rover missions called
honeybee robotics in New York City and
after a while I thought it'd be nice to
maybe take a break from all that rocks
and dirt basically you know and I
figured I'd go to Carnegie Mellon to do
robotics robotic vehicle development
work and my advisor told me you know
once i was there you know about this
it's exciting Mars you know like a lunar
rover project to develop a new lunar
rover and I told me what the task was it
was to support drilling down into the
soils so I started to wonder if this was
a thread in my career that I was kind of
inescapable and then later ended up here
now at this near Earth autonomy which is
a spin-off company from Carnegie Mellon
from the field robotics center and now
you know major project the moment is
this agriculture project and so we end
up a lot of this data we're making
aerial observations on on the crops and
end of the soils so the thread continues
and I'm embracing it I think it's great
to be in the field i think the other
more more important threat i think is
that i've enjoyed getting to work on
systems that are collecting data for
scientists to make progress in their
areas so the this tara program is it's
been a great project for us in our
company to get deeper into the support
of agriculture from an aerial sensing
kind of angle so i think just to give
you a bit more of a just a picture of
what we're doing this tara program is
you know it's led by suppressive its use
API on our project at clemson we are the
team providing the aerial data
collection and some of the analysis from
there there's also a team at at carnegie
mellon doing ground vehicles so that
robotic vehicles driving through the
crops collecting data up close to the
crops so combining these these data
collection platforms outputs and
learning more about ways to accelerate
the breeding process so this is one of
the fields there these is exquisitely
planted fields in South Carolina outside
of Clemson seeing hundreds of varieties
of energy sorghum in this 12 acre field
and so we're you know well at this point
I think one of the ground vehicles was
driving making observations on the
ground while we're flying over and I
hope the two screens doesn't make anyone
motion sick even one screen might be
enough so you can see a lot of variation
in the in the fields us is definitely
not a typical farm right when you're
looking at breeding plots they there are
a lot of different traits in these
different varieties this is early this
is the first year out of three for this
project so we're starting up we're
looking at some of the
there are early refinements of the
breeding and an refinements of the data
collection techniques so they have two
fields in South Carolina ones in it's
right outside of Clemson and the other
is in in Florence so it's more as you
can see is this a reddish clay soil and
the Florence side is more coastal plains
sandy just nice to be work into two
different conditions so down for landing
so just for a little bit of background
on the company I met now it's we're
about 40 people it's about four years
old we were spinoff from Carnegie Mellon
field robotics Center you can think of
us as kind of this the convergence of
the standard aviation where you know
just basically flying it's good
technology of course but it's fairly
simple navigation usually flying
waypoints straight straight flight
fairly straightforward converging that
with more of all the kind of
intelligence that you're seeing more and
more on driverless cars the field
robotic center has actually placed it
that put out a lot of the people who are
at now at uber and at Google developing
these driverless cars that came out of
this DARPA Grand Challenges for for
these vehicles so so our group is a lot
of researchers that came from from that
area and so we're converging into this
this kind of near-earth autonomy so
basically the the company began where
it's more focused on the navigation
helping aircraft fly on their own down
near the ground where it's difficult so
we work in in the field a lot you know
we work on a lot of different you know
sizes of helicopters it's kind of cool
Shawn flying up over Pittsburgh or the
sing when the rivers on downtown this is
actually a autonomous flight with a full
scale helicopter there the upper left
and you know find a lot of different
conditions even out we're flying out
over Lake Erie lately helping a
helicopter land on to a hundred
large to show that we could operate from
ships so yeah we work with full-scale
helicopters and also kind of getting
into the more more where I'm focusing on
the mapping and inspection kind of work
is is in these the smaller kind of the
50 pounds and less kind of the that kind
of category of aircraft whether you know
like these quad copters and hexacopter
is that kind of stuff now there the
technology is really improving they're
easier to use and now they're the FAA is
allowed them to be used commercially
more and more so it's all it's all
working together to become actually
available and so that's kind of the way
we're working in for our agriculture
work so far so as a company we're
working a lot of navigation and mapping
and inspection that's kind of the three
kind of categories I think we have kind
of in our in our genes as a company this
history in agriculture there's a fairly
big project the USDA funded years ago
where some of the founders where were
working on with specialty crops this is
all ground vehicle based but making
observations in the field with specialty
crops and nurseries and landscape
industry and so that's excellent the
connections I think with Marcel to Steve
and so now our current work is we're
focused on this accelerated plant
breeding using the aerial reconnaissance
essentially to help the breeding process
and also trying to spin that off into
more farm management helping growers and
so you could see you could imagine we're
kind of working with the kind of early
adopters at this point kind of breeding
groups that are that are fairly high
tech think of them you know who function
that way and also some of them may be
larger growers that be open to adopting
this kind of stuff early mostly working
with with energy sorghum but we're also
looking some matinees and
and grapes so this boost is our team
it's our project under the Tara program
there are six different Tara projects
and so it's it's the Department of
Energy's arpa-e it's like it's their
their DARPA for energy applications and
so I think it's a fantastic program the
goal for Tara as a whole is to support
you know to basically accelerate to this
breeding process to get this really good
potential of energy sorghum as a
sustainable biofuel source and also
along the way develop new techniques for
for breeding for accelerated breeding
for in and looking at high throughput
few know typing in the field as a as the
main kind of method for that so we're
looking into your basic trying to
support this development of predictive
algorithms you know you get data early
in a growing season and predict the you
know harvest kind of results be able to
assess a variety really early and then
just get get more of these detailed
measurements of the plant physiology and
then focusing a lot on the data
analytics and connecting the genotypes
two phenotypes that kind of mapping so I
don't know if this this might give you
motion sickness to potentially but it's
right you can imagine that where this
first thing we're essentially developing
these phenotype phenotyping hardware
systems getting them into the field so
that they can collect data both on the
ground and in the air taking these
results and putting them in through an
analysis pipeline including machine
learning techniques and then doing this
phenotype to genotype mapping and
feeding that all back into the field so
that we you know if three growing
seasons to work so this cycle goes
throughout the project
so just thinking about our activity in
the field for this program we've got
these ground vehicles by that Carnegie
Mellon are making their driving through
the rows getting doing be able to do
this close proximity kind of sensing you
know you're you're right up against the
plants they're doing stereovision lidar
other sensor types then they're also
doing things that are contact sensing
which i think is pretty novel where
they're actually interacting physically
with the plant you know measuring from
one thing I'm focusing on right now is a
penetrata tour testing on the strength
of the stalks so it actually it's a
gripper that visually you know
automatically finds the stock grabs it
and does a penetrometer test and as it
goes through the road and then there's
also a sensing network for environmental
characteristics on the ground and then
we're the team that's doing that the
aerial sensing so yeah we've got this
this aircraft flying overhead you know
40 to 60 feet kind of above the ground
doing mapping the whole field with a
custom sensor package so that's that's a
bulk of our work is developing this
custom sensor package we don't develop
the aircraft we don't develop sensors we
choose aircraft for the for the purpose
and we choose the sensors for the
purpose in integrate and then work with
that data make sure the data can be
fused well it's registered well
spatially it's calibrated well in terms
of energetics and bring that data
together and make it make it useful so
this is a picture of our our first
sensor package for this project it ended
up kind of looking like a micro
satellite or something this is about six
or seven pounds maybe you could hold it
in your hands like this and it rides on
board the aircraft and is completely
self-contained black box thank you
essentially like a very tricked-out
GoPro you know you hit start it records
from all of its six sensors and then
also simultaneously it is estimating its
position and an orientation
the world as it goes so that way we're
not just taking it's not just flying
over with a camera and then stitching
together imagery later that's fairly
straightforward it's actually it
estimates them where the sensor package
is and how it's how it's pointing so
that you can pull together really
explicitly mapped so every pixel you
know exactly where it hits on the ground
and so you can make this very accurate
at very accurate maps three men tionally
in some cases so these are the aircraft
we're working with this is a 35-pound
electric autonomous helicopter on the
left and then this is a similar weight
there's a hexacopter we're using now so
we're kind of showing both you know
there are different categories in terms
of cost and complexity and also
performance in some ways the helicopter
can get a lot more coverage for larger
fields faster fly more wind conditions
but the hexacopter is really easy to use
and so you know where I think most of
time will be operating from that but so
we tried to start kind of from you know
first principles in a way on deciding
what was going to be in that sensor
package so we ended up going through
that process ended up with these for
sensing modes so 14 to try to get at the
shape of the crops Co geometric
properties we're experimenting with
lidar so its units laser scanner there
that's that disc kind of puck shifting
in the front so it's scanning across the
ground with with infrared laser points
and building up a three cloud and then
to get at kind of color properties and
also geometric properties using visible
imaging just standard RGB imaging to
look at temperature related properties
and some stress plant stress or using
the thermal infrared so it's just
monochromatic long-wave infrared and
then
to be a little more ambitious we're also
added in hyperspectral camera so you
know with typical camera you think of
color it's three three bands right red
green blue that you can think of those
three separate layers if you really look
at the sensor on a color camera it's
actually red green blue and another
green it's a pattern of for for
everything of you think of as one pixel
and so so you know you're getting those
three separate bands for hyperspectral
we're using a camera that is 100
spectral bands and they're all they're
not overlapping at all they're all
separate very narrow bands there and
it's cutting across the kind of red and
visible and up into the near-infrared
through in pretty far into that
near-infrared so there's going there
we're taking a lot of inspiration from
the remote sensing approaches from
satellite and where they they have all
these interesting indices well they'll
say this spectral band ratioed with this
spectral band ends up correlating really
well with this kind of plant property
and so and so they're we're thinking
that through this whole combination
hyperspectral in particular I think
we're going to get to explore and look
for these properties you predicted
things these correlations to plant
properties and and be able to I think
we'll learn quite a bit and then also
get to do a second generation in the
second year of this payload we're out of
the sensor suite where it'll be more
refined and found it a bit cheaper to
sobe closer to being commercialized
so here's a shot of us it's in the field
this is the sand layer site there in
South Carolina and there's the sensor
package writing down below on one of the
multi rotor copters so it's pretty
straightforward it takes just a couple
people to operate in the field it takes
off and and collects data all along
lands we here's a shot of us it was the
last month
I would lower the volume but I don't
know how I tried so you can see it's
just it takes off really simple to
operate this thing even though it's a
pretty serious aircraft in a way I mean
it's still do have to be very careful
we're following all the FAA regulations
we have registered pilots like the guy
who was actually piloting this he
manually made it take off and then
flipped it into autonomous mode for to
do its kind of simple lawnmower kind of
pattern over the crops but he he used to
fly Apache helicopters for a long time
in South Korea so that's him there
Spencer so he's kind of unfazed by this
stuff luckily
so yeah the flying portions is easy you
know it's just just as long as you
follow all the right procedures and keep
everything legal and safe it's all very
straightforward stuff it's not novel
technology there it's off the shelf but
so in all the all our focus is in the in
making it sensor suite correct and
making the data worthwhile so here's
just a series of frames just of what
this so it's all straight down looking
cameras this is just some of the visible
data from you know from the RGB camera
and then just a example of what some of
that looks like once you start to build
these orthographic maps from from the
imagery to get a sense of kind of
resolutions we're getting this was
flying a little on the high side about
60 feet above ground level I was showing
Steve some of the weeds on this shot and
then just you know better sense doing in
so you're getting many pixels across a
leaf you know that kind of a spatial
resolution seeing color variations in
texture in the panicles of these these
sort of implants most of the time we're
playing over energy sorghum so the
panicles aren't there but in some cases
we are you're also seeing you know we
will be able to be pulling out
information about the leaf geometries
we're also seeing some lodging here as
an example I think that's something we
could probably pull out automatically
and so then another data product is this
the lidar data so this is this point
cloud that we get this isn't cleaned up
or anything it's just basically what it
sees as its flying and so it's just a
real 3d model it's like flying around in
a in a strange video game afterwards
right you just it's you can actually
take measurements between points you can
so you're essentially able to just after
the fact go through and measure
geometric properties so so that later
you get this
3d model that you can you know spin
around map in different ways process in
different ways and get to 3d information
so those are some vans vehicles and
tents here in that big open aisle and so
you're seeing a lot of the color
variation it's a color scale as applied
just to visualize the differences in
heights so it's like a heat map for a
for height so you're saying a lot of
these plots or clearly are different
varieties and so you're saying a fair
amount of variation in in the height by
plot that's actually one of the
phenotype that we're focusing on these
last couple of weeks is cleaning up a
way to produce a good measurement of
plant height averaged out by plot so
this data kind of lends itself to that
to be able to know what your kind of
characteristic height is for each plot
and the amount of variation in height in
that plot and getting more and more
appreciation for how it sounds easy but
isn't easy and i Justi idea of I heard
story of ice to crest which told us a
story of a group with their I think
maybe six pretty respected you know
faculty members on this one program and
a set program and multiple of them were
in the National Academy of Sciences and
it took them months to argue out how to
measure the height of the plant and now
I understand that a little bit better
the idea of you know if it has a panicle
or not does that influence your height
measurement is the leaf is a leaf
pointing up or down does that mean the
plan is a different height is it is the
wind blowing things you know what your
met what your standard method how a
person would do it versus what can you
actually do from from the air so this is
I think we're getting more and more
appreciation for for some of these
things for the sensitivities here's just
a just another shot of the light our
point cloud this is the van
they're in the top 4 scale so as we fly
we're registering the data using GPS and
inertial sensing within the payload it's
completely separated just is along for
the ride on the aircraft it's not
interacting with the the aircraft
controls we're also experimenting with
targets on the ground to help tighten up
the spatial registration even more on
the calibration there's um you know we
worked some extent with what the
manufacturers give us as far as may the
calibration of cameras but then we're
also doing our own quite a bit in some
ways we're redoing and improving things
that the manufacturers do especially for
the energetics on like the hyperspectral
camera we're doing things where we give
different light source inputs put and
then so during lab calibration then also
field calibration laying out tarps in
the field taking off and landing from a
calibration target more or less and then
we're experimenting something with the
with shadowing to the intent there's
just to make sure that the data has is
closely tied to the real physics of the
plant there's real plant properties and
aren't influenced by too much by the
changes in in lighting conditions which
can be pretty significant it would be
like you know like if you with
photography right if you're messing
around with different white balances you
imagine it being very different and
that's just trying to make things look
appropriate if you are trying to make
physical deductions then it's even more
important so with our our analytics
trying to support we've we've got these
foundational things ways of modeling
what the ground shape is and segmenting
into plots and annotating things
producing these raw data products like
just you know just the standard things
that are collected right off the camera
and then these reduced products these
you know image maps and 3d models and
then these more of a derived data
products is where we're starting to put
more focus into now things where it's
not like like a phenotypes you know
plant traits trends in these plant
traits
and then I will be supporting the the
rest of the team at Clemson where Steve
cressa Fitch's team is and the Danforth
center where they'll both be doing a lot
of the effort of making correlations
between the phenotypes and genotypes and
feeding that into the breeding process
so I think I describe those really well
I think just to get a sense of some of
the other phenotypes were going after
things like you know observing be able
to map out when when emergence happens
we're across the field measuring the
plant height / plot and then that how
that changes over time whether or not
there's a panicle so the things like
canopy closure leaf area index lodging
you know the plants have fallen over
there just other geometric types of
things there's stress like water stress
or nitrogen stress or leave necrosis and
anything we can learn about another
photosynthetic activity I think from our
hyperspectral camera we hope to be able
to pick that out pretty well and other
hyper spectral indices that could maybe
have kind of novel correlations that
will find in this project so in the end
I think you know once these become more
refined you know the hope is that we're
giving advice to breeders feeding into
their their analysis chains and advice
for growers to you know how to how to
better manage their their fields and so
that they're they're not just given you
know like say Oh earlier this week we
had our people who are in the field in
South Carolina they came back with 1.3
terabytes and they only flew I think six
times and so you know a grower doesn't
want that you know that my a lot of us
you know you do to just be kind of blown
away by that it's just not useful I
think Stephen I were talking in the
other they're busy already you know
they're not looking for a boring he'll
be on top of their job
so we're trying to refine this software
process so that they're given something
that's more like actionable intelligence
to use term from that world so it's just
basically what do i do give me advice
and so the arpa-e program Tara is really
consciously pushing us to think about
commercialization we've kind of
identified a lot of different potential
ways that things could go this we could
transition this technology to market in
the end you know collecting a huge
amount of data in the field I think that
could be valuable just the straight data
being analysis analysis algorithms could
potentially be licensable the the
vehicles and the sensing packages and
then also you can imagine the whole
integrated you know typing system of
ground and air and analysis and then I
think we could very well make
significant progress on actual new more
refined varieties of energy sorghum
throughout this project so I think
looking ahead a bit we're hoping to you
know extend the work on to other target
crops you know a lot of our sensor
approaches and analysis approaches
aren't you know completely specialized
to energy sorghum you know they could
easily be applied to other other crop
types or even other other areas beyond
specifically crops like surveying for
Disease in natural you know in trees
that's something that has been coming up
in Pennsylvania area lately in
discussions so we're hoping we're trying
to line up more field trials with large
farms and smaller innovative farms we've
got people in the area you know like
Pittsburgh is such a you know robotics
kind of mecca that you know we get lucky
that there's no farmer and the outside
of town who's just supports our work so
we get to operate there a lot work with
his on his crops and so it's a nice
sample of that we're going to be doing
some breeding trials in Australia and
trying to find a way to stay active
during the winter here so that will be
there in a outside of Melbourne this
winter so I think some good potentials
there and then so this is a three-year
program with Tara and so we're hoping to
continue that to there's some potential
there once some some funding matching
happens so that could continue the work
make it more refined may be taking some
different different directions so yeah I
think it'd be great if you anybody had
any questions be happy to answer those
thank you very much involved any
questions I have a question I noticed
that the the fly to fly over that you
showed us it was a overcast day does it
matter you prefer overcast vs sunny or
yeah yeah I overcast is nice actually it
ends up with much more diffuse light
less shadowing yeah it's kind of like I
guess like doing photography it's
counterintuitive maybe but yeah yeah we
don't really we're trying to just get
the the processes right so that we can
deal with either conditions you know
with but but shadowing is is hard to
work with you know the idea if you want
to see down into the end of the crops
not just the top layer then it gets
tricky I can muddy thing's for sure just
you end up with dynamic range issues you
know that make a very well lit leaves
and you know portions of the plant and
some part of the scene and then very low
lighting on other portions it's hard to
get useful data across the whole range
you are you able to focus on particular
quite small parts for example
all right right so yeah so as far as the
data collection goes we are just
covering the entire field and and we do
it from two different directions so
we'll cover it say like east to west and
then go back again north-south and so
you get a fair amount of you get very
complete coverage and then you get a
fair amount of kind of penetrating
observations like down through
especially you know early and mid season
down to the soils and lower portions of
the plan and that you have with the
analysis I think separating out soils
from from plant material is a fairly I
think pretty straightforward thing that
will be will be doing soon and then it's
it's hard to say how far we'll get to go
with breaking out automatic automated
sort of way different portions of the
plant but I hope that we could at least
pick out panicle and leaves separate of
the rest of the scene
right yeah so that's a um it's a it's
fairly low resolution it's an imager
from FLIR company clear it so it's um
it's about 640 pixels across and it's so
that's just because of the state of the
art you know with color imaging you we
have a 12 megapixel camera on board but
this is a you know one megapixel camera
just because that's kind of the top of
what's available right now and luckily a
lot of the thermal thermal properties in
the field are a fairly coarse spatially
speaking or fairly coarse things so I
think it's still useful and so I think
early on it might you know it's a early
in the season it might be a little bit
muddy where you know pixels are
overlapping a lot with you know some
it'll be half landing on a leaf and half
on soil but I'm later on what's the
canopy starts to close I think it'll be
pretty clean sensing of canopy kind of
thermal emission yes yeah primary yeah
primary yeah I think we might get to see
some in the hyperspectral too but I
we're hoping to see the stress mostly in
the thermal
we are planning for about once every
four weeks we we're also on the hook to
show that we could operate more than one
time a day you know they do full
coverage of a fairly large field like a
five hectare field twice per day so
that's that's more of a demonstrate to
arpa-e that we can do that kind of
coverage but in the real field trips
will be there once essentially once per
month it's it's a bit I think at some
point that you know it would just be so
close together that there would be much
value but so that's you know as kind of
roughly chosen that we should be able to
see quite a bit of change in in four
weeks and but you know I think later in
that maybe the third season we're hoping
to just keep the system keeping keep the
the aircraft down there at the field and
it could be operated more frequently
than that so yeah we could experiment
some to see if there's more utility and
more frequent trips yeah
right yeah completely I know we I think
I'm hoping to talk more about some soil
potentials you be nice to hear here's
some advice for me on that I think it's
you know especially when its large large
areas to survey it's you know the aerial
approaches seems really good for that
and yeah so I think there's a there's a
good potential there and then yeah we've
had some first conversations with some
people about some of the pests pest
management and so yeah I think it could
be I think a lot of ways it would see
we'd maybe be observing I think so that
we've seen on the ground you know we're
actually the ground vehicle from is
actually seeing a fit and the images and
you're actually picking out things to be
able to recognize them but from us from
the aerial point of view we'd probably
see more of the the effect on the plant
which Soviet slightly indirect but still
I think valuable we haven't actually
been considering it in depth yet I think
it's I think there's a lot of good
potential for it but um you know we
there this you know I think just if to
see changes you know seeing motion of
soil you know if there's the 3d data is
so good you know from our lidar that I
think if you're able to see any
redistributions of soil I think they
could be really good for picking it out
over time we've done stuff where you can
see small changes in a scene just you
know from one flight to the next that
kind of thing but then also with the you
know picking out things like color and
thermal and hyper spectral we might be
able to see other processes that are
going on in the soils so yeah be nice to
hear advice on there yeah
huh
right
yeah that's a good question we yeah
you're right we've been focusing on just
this one you know all these different
varieties of sorghum and it's more our
focus has been more about yeah the kind
of basic traits but yeah I think
actually Stephen I were talking this
morning a little bit about trying to
differentiate you know crops from weeds
and so I think we're talking about
different methods for that I think from
this you know high resolution visit
camera you know they are just visible
data we could get at some of the
geometric properties you know say some
character some characteristics they're
pretty reliable like the shape of the
leaf or the way the leaves are branching
that sort of thing could be a pretty
reliable way to differentiate between
plant types and then also i think the
spectral signatures could be potential
on that so we're you know just something
pretty a good correlation say you know
something in you know has some kind of
spectral signature in the infrared maybe
in the near infrared that say corn
disorder was very different so yeah it's
something we haven't done but it yeah
but these these types of sensors could
could maybe do it though thanks
for your stress and you might have to
think about
yeah yeah I think so i guess yeah saying
once that's good advice i think we've
been going going to the side once per
month but like say this week for
instance we had um we had some flights
kind of late afternoon on one day and
then kind of a earlier morning I guess
is more mid day the next day so
temperatures and lighting conditions
were different but still you know the
state of the Cross was essentially the
same so yeah that's that's probably yeah
you're right that something that would
be really good practice yeah how would
you imagine that software and have
someone come in with the hardware or
cell right hardware television network
maybe have any idea
right later on mmm all right sure yeah
well we're actually we're trying to work
on kind of three different you know
business models really you know the from
our company's point of view that I think
licensing the software is probably the
you know the the quickest and easiest
way to market but you know selling an
integrated hardware package you know
where it's the whole thing basically the
aircraft in the payload or selling just
the sensor payload those are very
valuable to you know it the most of the
I think it's really hard to get to get
much revenue from aggregate which
profiting is from just selling Hardware
packages really but it's you selling it
more as a service I think could be
actually better in a lot of ways because
a lot of the end users don't really
necessarily want to get into operating
these things or dealing with owning them
maintaining them and all that but they
like the data so just for them to hire a
service to come in and collect the data
and give them the data is probably a
really nice model I think in that case
we probably our company wouldn't we
would be the technology developers and
owners of the intellectual property but
another service providing firm would
probably do that so that that's those
are the licensing in the servicing about
the two models that are probably the
most likely to work out well and then as
farce costs you know we you know the
aircraft side of things it's you know
that helicopter working with this is
something like you know sixty thousand
dollars then the the smaller one the not
a smaller but the hexacopter one is more
you know it's more of a standard product
now it's more you know commercially
available broadly from that DJ I that
one's about fifteen thousand dollars if
you get for all the all the hardware
needed so that's a lot more attainable
for people and then especially you know
growers and then the sensor package
we're looking to get that down from
you know like a the very ambitious you
know the one you know working with now
something like 75 k for just the
hardware right not the labor to build it
or get it running but then second
generation we're going to bring that
down probably you know more like 40,000
in hardware and then a commercialized
version of that down even further maybe
hopefully more like 25 so maybe even
lower yeah with numbers you know add
with manufacturing scale that could go
even lower so well Paul has told me that
that he does maybe have a few slots open
on his afternoon schedule so
yeah it'll be great any any advice or
questions really great really appreciate
you coming thank you once again this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu